look look man look for first off let's
let's talk bro let's talk for a minute i
know this review is late i know it's a
couple weeks since the game came out but
i apologize it took me that long to beat
this game this game is a very long time
and it took me about a hundred plus
hours to beat this game i didn't get a
review copy or anything like that i
played it from the day it came out to
probably about two days ago i've been
getting my thoughts together writing
down information exactly what i feel in
terms of the game elden ring and that's
what this is this is a review on eldon
ring developed by from software i
reviewed this on the xbox series x but
before we get on with the review you
guys know how it is hit that like button
if you guys enjoy the video you can
always subscribe to the channel we do
weekly podcasts on this channel and i
hope you guys enjoy but without any
further ado here's my review on eldon
ring for the xbox series x
[Music]
what's going on you guys lord addicts
here coming at you for another review
let's talk a little bit about the
history that i have with from software
games i started this venture back on
dark souls
and i was always one of those people
that was very hesitant to play these
type of games but one of my buddies
convinced me to actually attempt this
game called dark souls
and i ended up loving it i remember
getting the black halberd in that game
and just loving that type of combat that
from software game was giving us with
dark souls then i went to dark souls 2
and i wasn't really the biggest fan of
that one i actually didn't beat dark
souls 2 and i played a lot of dark souls
3 but i never officially beat dark souls
3. but i did beat bloodborne and i beat
sakura shadow dice twice
so when it comes to this type of game i
remember when i first heard of eldon
ring i wasn't really that hyped i don't
know why i've always loved the from
software games but it's never been like
my go-to for the best experience in
gaming to me first off let's talk about
the graphics and performance of eldon
ring on the xbox series x first let's go
into the graphics a little bit now i
know a lot of people are trying to say
this game has like ps3 texture graphics
and it's got some grass from the
playstation 3 air don't listen to none
of that like look is this the most
beautiful game you're ever going to play
in your entire life
probably not like i do think that they
need to increase the output of their
graphics ever since something like demon
souls came out late late last year on
the playstation 5 it was one of the
exclusives for that and now i know it's
not made by the same company that was
made by blue point this is made by from
software but that was that was from
software's game so to me if you're gonna
let another company show off your
current games then you know you got to
step it up with your next title now this
game made a lot of money so i would
expect that their next game is going to
double dip on everything graphics wise
and look are we going to get the perfect
thing no i just feel like of demon souls
and we're getting this next-gen hardware
well it's current gen at this point now
sometimes when you're traveling in this
game across the multiple type of biomes
that's in this game some places look
amazing in some places not quite that
much it's like i said it's a very
inconsistent game and it's like i'm not
trying even remotely to tell you this
game looks bad it's passable i think if
you play this you're not going to really
bicker too much on how the graphics look
now if you're one of those people that
you want your graphics look really
realistic and look really eye candy then
you're probably going to be disappointed
with this but i feel like from software
games at this point they're more known
for their gameplay than the visual
lookers they're not visually looking but
they're they're average but the gameplay
is usually where they shine in these
type of games and it's like i said the
only thing i can really say when it
comes to the graphics is they really
need to to amp it up next time man you
guys gonna make a lot of money on eldon
ring when you start making the next gen
games you know the xbox series x ps5 i
keep saying next gen they're really
current joe but you guys get what i'm
saying make sure you push the envelope
make this game look amazing on top of
the amazing gameplay that you currently
always have one thing you could say
about from software is they show up big
time when it turns to gameplay now let's
talk about the performance of this game
now look i will mention disclosure
already i didn't play this game when the
majority of the people were having
issues with it i played it day one and i
know a lot of people saying there was
issues day one i didn't really
experience too much of that now i
experienced a couple crashes nothing to
write home about nothing that i feel
like would really devastate the review
and how i thought about the game it was
more of an inconvenience unnecessarily
game breaking to me there is a lot of
frame rate issues on some of the bosses
now it's not everything i only really
experienced it like maybe once or twice
in the whole game where sometimes these
bosses have these crazy attacks and i'm
assuming it's putting a lot of stress on
the the system where it does go down
dramatically in frame rates we're
talking maybe 20 frames 30 frames
somewhere around there i'm not technical
like that so i could really tell you but
it was enough where i noticed it off the
rim like it wasn't just a little bit it
was a lot and you know for the most part
i can honestly say the performance of of
eldon ring on the xbox series x keep in
mind guys i didn't play this on pc i
didn't play this on playstation 5. i
played this on the xbox series x and i
never had no issues when it comes to
something like that now let's talk about
the story now first off let's talk about
how much i'm going to make a lot of you
from software fans upset with this
segment there's a lot of things i feel
like they can improve on here but let's
talk about the stuff that i really
enjoyed first elden ring has a very
immersive world when you're riding
around on your horse when you know
you're going into these newer biomes and
pretty much that sensation of being in a
new area they do that very
very well uh one thing i can honestly
say about eldon ring is look i do feel
like the story sometimes could tell
itself a little bit better but for the
most part they do a pretty good job at
you know building up some of these
characters not all of them i feel like
they could do better on some of these
characters that you found like the round
table and stuff and that might be
necessarily because of gameplay choices
that we'll go into later on and i liked
it i really enjoyed the world of elden
ring now let's talk a little bit about
the thing that i feel like a lot of you
is going to be upset with now before i
say this
i am not coming at your guys's game okay
i'm not trying to change it drastically
i love this game but i do want to
vocal this opinion
it is okay to put quest logs it is okay
to do more stuff on the map
i don't think when i see people
constantly talking on twitter and
constantly you know being very vocal
about the fact that elden ring and from
software don't hold your hand in terms
of information on the screen i don't
think that's really anything to brag
home about there's nothing wrong with
telling your player yo you have a quest
there's no nothing wrong with telling
your player there's an npc on this part
of the map you don't have to put all
these question marks and stuff that you
would see you know like an assassin's
creed game but you can tell your players
certain things they do it to a point in
this game or they will tell you where
the maps are to open up your map they'll
tell you where certain caves are on the
map if you go buy them so they do tell
you information it's just i guess to me
like if you took a couple days off of
elder ring like you had a work and you
couldn't really play it you came back
you probably forgot most of the quests
that you've been talking these npcs with
i was finishing quest on eldon ring and
didn't even know i started a quest and
i'm sure a lot of you loved that but to
me if you're happy to write down
information i actually saw someone on
twitter say if you're gonna play eldon
ring to have a notepad about the npcs
you came across where you came across
them look man we don't need to go this
extra with this you can have an
immersive world and you can still inform
your players of key things that's on the
map that's all i'm going to say there
now i know a lot of you like that aspect
of elder ring i'm just not one of them
so we're going to agree to disagree on
that one all right so let's talk a
little bit about the story in terms of
some of these
random bosses that's in dungeons now
look they do a good job with bosses in
this game there's a lot of memorable
bosses that is from from software that's
going to be a staple with their games
it's just because they've made this an
open world type of game they have this
scenario where they throw these random
dungeons in the map with a random boss
at the end they definitely you know
re-skin certain trolls and certain
enemies and they've actually brought
certain enemies from previous souls
games into this game and i'm okay with
that because i feel like that's more fan
service than anything else i don't think
that was anything you know what people
would call cheap or something where they
didn't want to make new assets they just
wanted to give you some fan service man
you guys remember this enemy from dark
souls 2 dark souls 1 dark souls 3. well
guess what he's in this game and i think
a lot of people really appreciated that
from from software but the issue that i
have is these random trolls that is
behind these dungeons and some of these
random stuff that you come across is
there a lore to some of these things yes
but i feel like we've gotten to the
point where from software it's like we
need to do a better job of informing
them like look we love your game and we
love the way you tell your story it's
just i personally feel like they can do
some of these things better where
instead of having 50 to 60 random bosses
behind dungeons have 25 and have good
lore building up to them i felt like
some of the demigods now look they have
there were amazing fights i cannot go
away from that i cannot express that
enough the fights in a lot of these is
amazing and some of them they do a good
job of explaining more than others but i
do feel like you have to go out and look
for this information and it's not
necessarily where i want it in my face
but i want to build up to a climax to
fighting some of these people and it's
like i said some of them they do a
really good job with but i do feel like
they can improve on that aspect
from software is a very talented
developer and you know i felt like
something like bloodborne they did a
great job with something like sakura
shadow dice twice they did a great job
with telling a story the way you want it
to be towed but not being thrown into
your face but this game i felt like
there was a lot of fluff in it there's a
lot of dungeons that they put in the
game just so you can farm xp and i don't
like stuff like that now sure it's not a
big deal in the overall sense of the
game but when you go into another
dungeon you find these crystallized
things for the third or fourth time to
me just became really exhausting after a
while it's like i said it's nothing
against the whole game this is nit
peeking to its finest it is kind of
important to me that they would have
made these uninteresting bosses with no
real lore behind them i get it there's a
lot of them but like i said i would have
preferred them to half the amount of
optional bosses and really build up
those bosses than just throw random
re-skinned trolls five or six times but
that's just me now let's talk about the
bread and butter when it comes to from
software games the gameplay i've always
felt like they perfected this type of
gameplay where people have adapted it to
a point and you've seen it sprinkle a
little bit throughout the industry in
terms of other games and eldon ring
doesn't seem to be any exception it
seems that they took that existing
formula and they made it better now is
anything different no i've always been
one of those people that says you don't
have to do stuff different just do it
better than you did it previously got a
lot of fans that have been buying from
software games for the past 10 years
that love that type of gameplay from
from software so i don't expect them to
really change it too too drastically now
what i've always enjoyed about from
software games and they really deliver
on here is the diversity gameplay they
let you play these how you want to play
you can play as a mage you can play as a
faith user you could play as a warrior
and you could play something that's a
little bit of overall thing where they
have multiple of those things in one
build where you know you have a warrior
with some faith enhancements or you know
you're worried that you throw some
spells in there there and the best part
about everything i said is that is
entirely up to you how you want to play
eldon ring weapons is returning
obviously in eldon ringing i could say
they're actually pretty well done the
majority of these weapons feel unique
they they feel nice when you attack them
and what i've really always enjoyed
about from software games and eldon ring
is no exception is when you see someone
use something generally you can snatch
that thing when you see someone have
armor on that you like oh that looks
pretty nice you can generally farm them
for that or sometimes if you can't farm
them you can find those weapons or find
that armor somewhere around the map now
obviously from software changed the
formula that they normally do most of
their games are kind of linear with a
little bit of branching opportunities in
terms of map design now from software
has always been masters of how they do
the map design but they've never went
full blown open world and they did that
with eldon ring and i can honestly say
that from software is one of the few
companies with developers that i've seen
attempt to do a full open world and do
it flawlessly is there issues with the
open world of course there's nothing
perfect in gaming nothing is i do feel
like some things could have been
differently in terms of you know how the
world unfolds now what's really cool on
here is there is actually like a day and
night cycle so there'll be more heavy
bosses come out at night there'll be
bosses in general just chilling
everywhere you can go around a random
field and band there's a dragon you can
go under some you know volcano band
there's like some fire wavering like i
really enjoy the sensation of just
traveling in eldon ring now clearly a
lot of you that's watching this you see
how hyped how successful eldon ring is
and i think this key point is why it's
successful when you have a player that's
never really played from software games
or maybe they hate from software games
you know kind of the person i used to be
in terms of from software back in the
old days with the demon souls the dark
souls uh you know sacro some of them had
a little bit of options that you could
do besides the boss that you were stuck
on but for the most part you were stuck
there till you beat that boss elder ring
it's not really the case now if you get
beat too many times fighting the boss in
eldon ring you can simply leave you're
not made to go there now sure some of
these times you'll get stuck on a main
boss and there's a couple of them in the
game but for the most part the amount of
bosses that's in this game overweigh the
amount of main bosses for example main
bosses is people you have to defeat to
continue the storyline you don't have to
do any of them for a long time for the
most part you can go on and do what you
want to do you could travel to my parts
of the map that you really shouldn't be
at you go to a part of the map that
you're not supposed to be there and
guess what you get one-shotted but the
ability is they give you the option if
you want to continue down that route or
do you want to turn around and level up
a little bit now obviously when it comes
to this this is what sold them i'm
confident that this game is going to
sell a lot of units just based off of
this and this alone it's inviting people
to play this game that doesn't really
have the experience of from software
games while keeping their hardcore
audience happy i'm really enjoying the
fact that they did this and didn't
really try to casualize the game too too
much now there's obviously issues with
elden ring in terms of you know i felt
like some of the lore could have totally
been better but i don't think none of
this really takes away from the fact of
how special this game is and i feel like
this is the kind of game that we only
get once every few years to maybe once a
generation from software has done such a
fantastic job explaining to people what
they need to do and explaining to people
why they need to buy this game giving
people the freedom the diversity to play
the game how they want that they did a
lot of things that i wouldn't
necessarily think would be possible in
modern time they've already sold 12
million copies keep in mind that the
iron lords podcast has bought three
copies of these because we wanted to
stream it we wanted to give the opinions
of myself on the review we bought three
copies so i know this game's doing good
eldon ring deserves your money there i'm
just going to say they deserve your
sixty dollars i do feel like there's a
lot of things that is wrong with elder
marine but the positive
drastically outweighs the negatives and
i think they deserve your money on
multiple times if you want a double dip
this is the only time i'll probably ever
say it's okay to double dip i'm not
really the biggest fan of double dipping
but if you want to play this on another
platform to play with your other friends
because it's not cross play or cross
progression i don't blame you that's how
good this game is eldon ring is the type
of game that i will be playing or
thinking about for years to come and i'm
kind of sad that my journey with this
game pretty much is over now i will be
playing the new game plus because it has
a new game plus but i don't know how
much long i'll play after that new game
plus has started because i'm the kind of
person that once a game has concluded
and i can't really get any more
information story wise normally i will
slowly drop the game after that now this
game might be different because i do
want to go back and i want to try some
of these overpowered mage builds i hear
about i want to try more of these
weapons that i've gotten that i don't
really need right now because i got kind
of a lock on the type of weapons that i
want to use i want to try all this stuff
and it has a lot of replayability but i
don't know if i'll actually go back and
replay these games it's like i said i
put 100 plus hours in this game and i'm
still constantly playing it and that
pretty much concludes the review of
eldon rank for the xbox series x it's
like i said solid graphics nothing
special nothing's gonna blow your mind
it's not like the state of the art in
terms of eye candy for the xbox or
anything in that matter because i've
seen it on the playstation five and i've
seen it on pc i'm sure the pc version
looks a lot better but as far as like
what the core graphics look like it's
nothing special performance is iffy
sometimes not a whole lot now it's like
i said i did not play this game before
the game came out when i was having the
most issues but i had a relatively solid
experience and the game plays probably
second to none it's an amazing gameplay
of diversity in games where you know if
you want to play as a mage cool you want
to play as a warrior cool if you want to
place everything wonderful they give you
the option they give you the freedom to
do so and that's the review for eldon
ring so definitely hit that like button
if you guys enjoyed this review it's
like i said man iron lords podcast we do
a podcast every 1pm on sunday definitely
tune into that you know we talk about
games such as eldon ring and pretty much
everything in the industry and until
next lord's review this is lord addict
i'm out of here peace